new legal action is being taken after a
deadly fire in downtown las vegas the
alpine motel went up in flames nearly
two years ago and six people lost their
lives there are now two new lawsuits in
this case one filed by a victim of the
fire a second by the building's owner
joe moller tells us how he claims he
isn't the only person responsible
i used to walk that way
a lot after the fire i just did not
natasha nguyen lives around the corner
from the alpine motel it's sad it's sad
over there it was christmas time
a lot of people lost their lives for
nothing six people died in the fire that
happened days before christmas in 2019
investigators say it was caused by a
stove being used for heat wind says it
could have been prevented people were
just
trying to get out and couldn't it's like
it was terrifying i know it was now yet
another victim is taking legal action a
new lawsuit was filed by kenneth gordon
who suffered an injury from jumping out
of a window it says exit doors had been
bolted shut forcing people to jump too
many violations too many cold violations
it was just terrible and he had him
people living like that he should get
whatever comes to him the owner adolfo
orozco is facing 25 different charges
including involuntary manslaughter and
negligence but now he is pointing
fingers at others a new lawsuit found by
orozco blames the on-site manager a
tenant the city of las vegas and three
companies connected to the building's
fire alarm system he says they weren't
doing their jobs keeping the motel safe
as more legal action is being taken gwen
just hopes justice is served for those
who lost their lives i just
say rest in peace said to the people
that god lost their lives there like
every time i go back by that
and that was joe mohler reporting
orozco's criminal case is on hold while
an appeal is being heard by the nevada
supreme court